how many of you have checked your email
today come on raise your hands how many
of you are checking it right now and how
about finances anybody check that today
credit-card investment account have it
this week now how about your household
energy use anybody check that today this
week last week few energy geeks spread
out across the room it's good to see you
guys but the rest of us this is a room
filled with people who are passionate
about the future of this planet and even
we aren't paying attention to the energy
use that's driving climate change the
woman in the photo with me is Harriet we
met her on our first family vacation
Harriet's paying attention to her energy
use and she is decidedly not an energy
geek this is the story of how Harriet
came to pay attention this is coal most
common source of electricity on the
planet and there's enough energy in this
coal to light this bulb for more than a
year but unfortunately between here and
here most of that energy is lost to
things like transmission leakage and
heat in fact only 10% to ends up as
light so this cold will last a little
bit more than a month if you wanted to
light this bulb for a year you'd need
this much coal the bad news here is that
for every unit of energy we use we waste
nine that means there's good news
because for every unit of energy we save
we save the other nine so the question
is how can we get the people in this
room and across the globe to start
paying attention to the energy we're
using and start wasting less of it the
answer comes from a behavioral science
experiment
was run one hot summer 10 years ago and
only 90 miles from here in San Marcos
California graduate students put signs
on every door in a neighborhood asking
people to turn off their
air-conditioning and turn on their fans
one quarter of the homes received a
message that said did you know you could
say 54 dollars a month this summer turn
off your air conditioning turn on your
fans
another group got an environmental
message and still a third group got a
message about being good citizens
preventing blackouts
most people guessed that money saving
message work best of all in fact none of
these messages worked they had zero
impact on energy consumption was if the
grad students hadn't shown up at all but
there was a fourth message and this
message simply said when surveyed 77
percent of your neighbors said that they
turn off their air-conditioning and turn
on their fans please join them turn off
your air-conditioning and turn on your
fans and wouldn't you know it they did
the people who received this message
showed a marked decrease in energy
consumption simply by being told what
their neighbors were doing so what does
this tell us well if something is
inconvenient even if we believe in it
moral suasion financial incentives don't
do much to move us but social pressure
that's powerful stuff and harness
correctly it can be a powerful force for
good in fact it already is inspired by
this insight my friend dan yes and I
started a company called oak power we
build software and partnered with
utility companies who wanted to help
their customers save energy we deliver
personalized home energy reports that
show people how their consumption
compares to their neighbors in similar
sized homes just like those effective
door hangers we have people comparing
themselves to their neighbors and then
we give everyone targeted
recommendations to help them save we
started with paper we moved to a mobile
application web and now even a
controllable thermostat and for the last
five years we've been running the
largest behavioral science experiment in
the world and it's working ordinary
homeowners and renters have saved more
than two hundred and fifty million
dollars on their energy bills and we're
just getting started
this year alone in partnership with more
than 80 utilities in six countries we're
going to generate another two terawatt
hours of electricity savings now the
energy geeks in the room know to
terawatt-hours but for the rest of us to
terawatt-hours is more than enough
energy to power every home in st. Louis
and Salt Lake City combined for more
than a year to terawatt-hours it's
roughly half with the u.s. solar
industry produced last year and to
terawatt-hours in terms of coal we need
to burn 34 of these wheelbarrows every
minute around the clock every day for an
entire year to get to terawatt-hours
electricity and we're not burning
anything we're just motivating people to
pay attention and change their behavior
but we're just one company and this is
just scratching the surface 20% of the
electricity in homes is wasted and when
I say wasted I don't mean that people
have inefficient light bulbs they may I
mean we leave the lights on in empty
rooms and we leave the air-conditioning
on when nobody's home that's 40 billion
dollars a year wasted on electricity
that does not contribute to our
well-being but does contribute to
climate change that's 40 billion with a
B every year in the US alone that's half
our coal usage right there now
thankfully some of the world's best
material scientists are looking to
replace coal with sustainable resources
like these and this is both fantastic
and essential but the most overlooked
resource to get us to a sustainable
energy future it isn't on this slide
it's in this room it's you and it's me
and we can harness this resource with no
new material science simply by applying
behavioral science we can do it today we
know it works and it will save us money
right away so what are we waiting for
well in most places utility regulation
hasn't changed much since Thomas Edison
utilities are still rewarded when their
customers waste energy they ought to be
rewarded for helping their customers
save it
but this story is much more than about
household energy use take a look at the
Prius it's efficient not only because
Toyota invested in material science but
because they invested in behavioral
science the dashboard that shows drivers
how much energy they're saving in real
time makes former speed demons drive
more like cautious grandmothers which
brings us back to Harriette we met her
on our first family vacation she came
over to meet my young daughter and she
was tickled to learn that my daughter's
name is also Harriette she asked me what
I did for a living and I told her I work
with utilities to help people save
energy
it was then that her eyes lit up she
looked at me and she said you're exactly
the person I need to talk to you see two
weeks ago my husband and I got a letter
in the mail from our utility it told us
we were using twice as much energy as
our neighbors and for the last two weeks
all we can think about talk about and
even argue about is what we should be
doing to save energy we did everything
that letter told us to do and still I
know there must be more now I'm here
with a genuine expert tell me what
should I do to save energy
there are many experts who can help
answer Harriet's question my goal is to
make sure we are all asking it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]